hey guys it's justine and today in front
of me we have one of the brand new
homepod minis they just released a bunch
of new colors they have obviously the
space gray and the white that they
previously had before but now they've
added a yellow orange and a darker blue
color i'm really excited about this
because i love the homepod so much i
feel like i'm one of the people that
definitely can account for a large
percentage of their sales over the past
couple of years i slowly went from one
home pod to two to three to four to
having my entire home be filled with
them so when the homepod mini did come
out i didn't really have a need to get
many of them but i do have a couple so
i'm very excited though for the colors
because this is kind of like a fun added
flair a little bit of decoration if you
will the main thing though to note is it
really is just a color upgrade there
isn't any tech difference between this
and the previous homepod mini but the
thing that they do have now is the voice
plan for apple music and why this is
kind of interesting is because before if
you would get a home pod you would want
to have an apple music subscription and
it would be even more expensive and you
basically only use your voice to talk to
your homepod so having this added 4.99
voice plan gives you the ability to have
all of the access to apple music
playlists telling siri to play you
different songs and i'll have to pay the
full price for an apple music
subscription i think that's going to
kind of be a really interesting thing
for a lot of people who don't have apple
music and maybe are just getting into
the homepod game for the first time and
if you are welcome it's nice here let's
open this up
look at this kind of hyped about this
because i have the
airpod max to match this and this is
definitely the color that was my
favorite of the new ones that were
announced we don't need to use a knife
but we're going to use a knife
[Music]
hi little homepod oh you're so cute
oh look at that
oh it's so nice i love the braided cable
the fact that the cable actually is an
accent color so it kind of matches
the orange homepod even the apple logo
check that out
the apple logo is even kind of like a
light orange salmony color i was
honestly hoping that they would have
released every single color to match the
imac because the purple imac is such a
nice color they even made the buttons a
little orange tint as well so it matches
this is nice look at that oh this is fun
we've got our
charging brick this is the 20 watt so
you do have to make sure if you have the
18 watt charging brick this will only
work with the 20 watt and i've made that
mistake i've gotten them mixed up before
so 20 watt
only okay let's plug this in oh i'm so
excited i just love the fact that apple
products are so easy to set up you
basically just like bring your phone
close to it it's magic it is actually
magic
so i got the new homepod all set up and
one of the things that i thought was
really cool is during the setup process
it actually recognized that this was the
orange homepod so in the setup dialogue
you can see that it is labeled with the
orange homepod now much like all of the
previous home pods and other apple
accessories it's so easy to set this up
you just bring your phone close to it it
automatically realizes that this is
something that needs to be set up and it
goes through the whole process i've had
homepods since the very beginning and i
love the fact that they did introduce
these new colors and this orange one
really just brightens up the space look
at this bright cheery happy i know it's
been a while since the original homepod
review video that i did but some of my
favorite features that they've added
recently is the intercom feature and
this is really fun because whenever my
sister comes over and has like a
sleepover or something like that we're
able to talk to each other from room to
room so there's one in her bedroom
there's one in mine i have one in the
kitchen you can either use the homepod
to do intercom or if you have your phone
up you can just hit the intercom button
up at the top uh tell jenna that it's
time to wake up and we're gonna go get
breakfast now
uh tell jenna that it's time to wake up
and we're gonna go get breakfast now i
probably could have just said hey jenna
we're gonna go get breakfast but for
some reason i always
end up acting like i'm talking to siri
and then telling her to tell somebody
something but you get the point the
other thing that i like with the power
of the u1 chip which is only in the
homepod mini and not in the larger
versions is you can bring your phone
close to it if nothing is playing it'll
automatically
pop up with some suggestions of things
to play this also works if you're
listening to something already or if
you're on a phone call you can transfer
it directly to your homepod one thing
that apple recently announced is the
apple music voice plan and this is 4.99
a month so instead of spending the 9.99
a month for apple music the voice plan
is 4.99 and you basically just use your
voice so you can basically tell siri to
play music playlists genres and all
sorts of things like that but you won't
have access to the actual app to create
playlists or scroll and search you can
only use your voice this might make
sense for some people who don't really
use their phone and they just use the
homepod as a music playing device or
something that allows them to have home
kit enabled in their home home kit is
incredible so with the home pod this
will allow you to connect all sorts of
home kit devices like lights locks
garage door openers all sorts of things
that are home kit compatible as long as
you have the homepod it'll give you
voice access to all of these devices so
i was looking at some things to see if
there was something that i didn't know
about the homepod this i actually did
not know you can tell siri to play
sounds of animals what sound does a cow
make
a cow sounds like this
what sound does a giraffe make here's a
giraffe
i'm i'm unsure if that's correct i don't
i've never heard a sound of a giraffe
before here's a hippopotamus
oh geez
i didn't like that if you have two of
these you can set them up as a stereo
pair and you can also have access to
your apple tv so you can have it control
start play stop all of those things you
can control with your voice on the
homepod later this year they're going to
be coming out with voice recognition
profiles so it'll be able to tell my
voice from my sisters so each be able to
have customized controls of the homepod
also very exciting you can now change
siri's voice you guys may have seen that
they changed this a while ago hi i'm
siri choose the voice you'd like me to
use i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri
i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri i'm
siri i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri i'm siri
i'm siri choose the voice you'd like me
to use that's what we're gonna use and
that's what i actually did have on for a
while and then i somehow said something
and siri picked it up and then it
started talking and i forgot that i
changed it to a male voice and i thought
there was a person in my home and i was
like what is happening and it turned out
it was it was our dear friend siri i
mostly use my homepod for playing music
so doing things like
play top 90s rock this is actually
really loud for such a tiny little
speaker
much like the previous version the top
is touch sensitive you can also adjust
your volume controls you can make it
louder or less loud you can also
obviously use your voice and tell siri
to turn the music down or up the weather
light it's currently clear in 81 degrees
temperatures are heading down from 81
degrees to 68 tonight so that was the
first look at the orange color of the
new homepod mini i'm really excited
about this and all the other colors if
you guys haven't got a home pot already
now it seems like a pretty great time to
do so they do start at 99 you can choose
from yellow orange blue the black and
the white it's also kind of exciting
again like i mentioned the voice plan
that is 4.99 so you don't have to get a
full music subscription you can just use
this as your home kit enabled device and
get the voice plan and still have all of
the access to apple music thank you guys
so much for watching i would love to
hear what you guys think leave me some
comments below and let me know if they
made a homepod color it is not already
out which one would you like to see them
make see you guys in the next video bye